Imagine I ask you to pick up my mom tomorrow at the airport.
Do you think you could find her?
No chance. What if I said my mom is coming in the airport tomorrow into Los Angeles
International Airport? Could you find her?
Still probably not. But what if I said she arrives at 3:42 p.m.
on flight 1717 from Dallas? Oh, and by the way, here's a picture of my
mom. could you find her of course what's the difference in this last instance I gave
you specific details to recognize my mom when she arrived this
is not too different from what God does in the Old Testament in preparation for the
coming Messiah who would be the Savior and liberator of the Jewish people and
ultimately of everyone when Jesus physically walked on earth it
had been hundreds of years since the last Old Testament book was written after
his resurrection Jesus was talking to his disciples Luke 24 reports that he talks to
them and says don't you understand that Moses and the prophets of the Old Testament
were speaking of me Jesus consistently understood his life as fulfilling the
people and events and prophecies of the Old Testament there are roughly
300 prophecies from the Old Testament, ranging from the minor to the major
that Jesus fulfilled. Let's briefly consider five of them.
First, the minor prophet Micah said the Messiah would be born in the small
town of Bethlehem and would have divine status.
As for you, Bethlehem Ephrathah, seemingly insignificant among the clans of Judah,
From you a king will emerge who will rule over Israel on my behalf, one whose
origins are in the distant past.
And as Matthew 2:1 reports, Jesus was born in Bethlehem, a small town of
only a few hundred.
2 Samuel 7 says that the Messiah would be from the line of David, the king.
In Romans 1:3, Paul confirms that Jesus was in fact a descendant
of David.
Isaiah 35:5-6 says that the Messiah would perform miracles, give sight to
the blind, heal the sick, and more.
In each of the Gospels reports, Jesus went from town to town performing these
remarkable miracles.
Isaiah 9:1 indicates that his ministry would be in the region of Galilee.
And again, as the Gospels consistently report, Jesus spent a considerable
amount of his time ministering in the region of Galilee.
Malachi 3:1 says a messenger would precede him.
And as Mark 1:3 reveals, John the Baptist prepared the way for Jesus.
You
might be thinking, the Gospel writers intentionally crafted their message to fit
Messianic expectations but this doesn't work for at least two reasons
first why would the apostles invent a view of jesus as
messiah they knew was false and then be willing to suffer and die for it the
fact that they were willing to suffer and die for jesus as messiah shows that they
were not making him up they had nothing to gain second while jesus did
fulfill old testament messianic expectations, the way he fulfilled it surprised
some people. Why would the apostles have invented a dying and rising Messiah?
A Messiah who was crucified as a criminal if they were trying to reach the Jews?
Such an invention would have been counterproductive to their message.
Some skeptics also push back and say, wait a minute, the prophecies are taken out of
context. For example, the Gospel of Matthew cites Hosea 11:1 in which it says
out of Egypt I will call my son well in its original context that was the nation of
Israel being brought out of slavery in Egypt but Matthew applies it to Jesus
is this a mistaken out-of-context false prophecy well we need to keep in
mind how the Jews would often interpret different passages Sometimes there was a one
-to-one correspondence, such as the Messiah being born in Bethlehem.
Other times there was a type or foreshadowing from the Old Testament that
was deeper fulfilled in the Messiah.
And in this case Israel was brought out of Egypt in the same way that Jesus brings
people out of slavery then and even now.
It's easy to see how some Jewish scholars have had a different expectation of
the coming Messiah, since they interpreted many of the prophecies differently.
They didn't have the hindsight, the value of looking back that we have today.
Think of it this way. What if you were given all these signs that the seasons were
changing? Leaves changing color, then falling to the ground, the air getting cooler,
the nights getting longer.
Imagine seeing this happen yet you had never seen or experienced winter before.
You'd be pretty surprised to wake up and see snow on the ground.
In hindsight it would start to make sense in fact you would begin to see the signs
come into focus.
We are fortunate today to be able to look back on the Old Testament and see
the hundreds of prophecies fulfilled in the life and death and ministry of
Jesus. When we look at the Old Testament through the lens of the person of Jesus, we
can see that he in fact is the long awaited Messiah.